in this video we'll talk about
huntington disease which is a
progressive
neurodegenerative disease
huntington disease is characterized by
uncontrolled and uncoordinated
dancing-like movement which is known as
korea korea is a greek word for dancing
this is a normal brain brain compared
with the huntington's brain certain area
in the brain
are degenerated in this disease
huntington disease affects the
functional abilities movement and motor
control it also lead to cognitive and
psychiatric problems
let's quickly look at the highlights of
associated with this disease first of
all it is characterized phenotypically
by dancing like movements known as
chorea
there are degeneration of a specific
type of neuron
in the brain region known as triatum
which controls motor activities
and that explains why there is
uncoordinated jerk like movement
the age of onset for huntington is 30 to
50 and this particular disease is
genetic that means it can be inherited
to the next generation in this video we
are going to talk about all these points
and going to discuss this thing in real
details so stay tuned and use a
headphone for better audio quality
so the major problem associated with
huntington disease is the movement
there could be problems in voluntary
movement as well as involuntary movement
so first of all we have discussed about
the jerking and writing movement problem
which is korea
along with korea there could be other
defects such as uncontrolled hand
movement slow and unusual eye movement
difficulty with speech and swallowing
when it comes to voluntary movements
there could be problems in muscle there
could be problem with muscle tone
dystonia is a common feature of
huntington disease
impaired gait and posture is another
prominent problem in huntington disease
generally human walk in a rhythm and
this is known as the bible gate
this gate or this rhythm is totally
disrupted in huntington's patient
other than that
depression is very common among
huntington's patient and also cognitive
decline is another feature and these
symptoms arise well before we can see
the clinical symptoms of huntington
disease
now let's talk about the progression of
the huntington disease
we can understand that in format of a
graph
here on the x-axis we have age and in
the y-axis we have
signs and symptoms expressed in
percentage and there are different
stages of the disease progression
presymptomatic prodermal early moderate
and advanced so gradually there is a
decrease in the functional abilities and
that's why it's a progressive
degeneration disease
there is increase in cognitive
impairments over the disease progression
also the motor impairments and
korea-like movement increases with the
advancement of this disease
initially the damage to the brain is
very regionally specific
and it affects an area which controls
the motor coordination this area is
known as the basal ganglia the basal
ganglia is pointed in red in this
particular view
in a coronal view we can see there are
certain
structures which are associated with
movements and basal ganglia so chordate
nucleus butamine globus pallidus
subthalamic nucleus and substantia [ __ ]
all these components together form the
basal ganglia
and in coordination with one another
this basal ganglia controls and
specially inhibits unwanted and
uncoordinated movements
that pretty much explains why in
huntington korea there is jerky or
korea-like movement
now the basal ganglia has specific type
of neuron which are inhibitory in nature
known as striatal medium spiny neurons
these neurons are gabaergic and inhibits
unwanted movements
in this particular motor coordination
circuitry
now in this disease we can see the
medium spiny neurons are actually
degenerated
and that results in the uncoordinated
surge of movements which leads to
korea-like dancing-like phenomena
so this particular disease is
genetically inheritable and the gene
responsible for huntington is present in
chromosome number four
generally in huntington gene there is a
cag repeat
and there are 10 to 25 repeats present
in normal individuals
whereas in huntington individual these
repeats range from 40 to 80.
so generally these repeats give rise to
glutamine residues
marked here in red
in huntington disease excessive number
of glutamine
residues can lead to aggregation of
these proteins which lead to
degeneration of the medium spiny neurons
and that is the key cause associated
with huntington disease
there is a strong correlation between
number of cag repeats and the prevalence
of huntington disease huntington disease
is more prevalent in european population
u.s population compared to asian or
african population
and it has been seen that number of cag
repeats are way lesser in these two
population compared to a european
population and european population has a
higher prevalence compared to asian or
african population
now genetic basis of huntington includes
an an inheritance pattern which is
autosomal dominant in nature so this
individual has one chromosome faulty
that means one chromosome has the
mutated huntington gene and this
individual is married to a normal woman
so it is
likely that their
two of their two out of four of their
offsprings would have the disease
that means 50 percent cases
the progeny would be affected and this
is a critical pattern of a typical
autosomal dominant trait
diagnosis of huntington disease can be
done using mri or eeg in eeg the
alteration take place in the alpha wave
forms
other than that if you have
huntington in your family you are always
prescribed to have a genetic counselling
for understanding whether you would be
affected or not sometimes the symptom
might not be visible but it is also
possible that you might be affected by
huntington so great a quicker diagnosis
would increase the chances of your
survival
life expectancy of huntington disease is
10 to 20 years from the onset
now
there are
major problems
such as pulmonary aspiration
and that leads to severe fatal pneumonia
which is the key cause of death in
huntington's
now there are no current treatment for
huntington disease but the symptoms
could be treated and
it could give a better lifestyle
and increase the lifespan at least a
little bit
so
there are few fda approved drugs
such as tetrabenzyme which
takes care of these hyperkinetic
movement
now
these anti-cordial drugs work via
depleting monoamine such as dopamine
serotonin from the nerve terminals
thereby taming down the hyperkinetic
movements seen in huntington disease
so i hope this was useful if you like
this
please give it a quick thumbs up you can
get many notes and flash cards in my
facebook page with the dynamic
notes and flash cards your preparation
would be super easy
check out my facebook and don't forget
to like share and subscribe support me
on patreon you can follow me on severe
social media all the links are provided
in description i'm also present in
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform using a code ap 10 you
can get a 10 discount see you in next
video